yo blue light cavs show special guest in
here about to do a stay man a little bob
in here man representing south carolina
hey before we have you uh first of all
my guys got the black amount on deck
first rapper to come in smoking just
black and mild just straight up you know
what i mean oh yeah sure we got the
blood on it no no there there's the
backwoods over here too as well
yeah um
uh you you uh talk about just just plug
your [ __ ] real quick you got soul bleed
out right now yeah i gotta solve it i
gotta take about to come out we got it
on hold right now we gotta get a couple
more [ __ ] uh verified and [ __ ] like that
and then attack gonna drop we got it
coming out soon though all right i sold
my latest drop right now and then uh
you know
for people who don't know what part of
south carolina you're from
it's in la spada attack
if you watch my latest interview you'll
know that uh it's a little small that's
how i decide
like on the outskirts of that [ __ ]
well look man we're gonna have you do
your thing bro so uh you know and you
came through with a fellow carolinas
beat uh shout out to the homie 2c yeah
uh yeah let's let's get it popping man
[Music]
easier to shot the bigger one
come from a place where you ain't
talking guns bigger than them
come from a place where young is told
girls bigger than them and he ain't
tripping cause that boy then got bigger
than him easy to shot the bigger the
real that's how they wanted
that's how they want it i've been in
those streets getting money ain't too
much tripping on the whole cause she
know how i go when i leave i ain't
tuning tripping on coming back we went
and got that money got some money but i
need some more and she a whole so i
ain't tripping on the way this [ __ ] go
i'm trying to [ __ ] it and leave her yo
[ __ ] didn't leave him yeah
[ __ ] didn't leave her yeah it's a
freestyle this [ __ ] comes straight up
off the top he ain't really bout no
money he ain't trying to get no i was
running at 12 years old from the cops i
was running at 12 years old from the
cops i seen that glizza getting dumped
seen another body drop that [ __ ] got me
traumatized
that [ __ ] got me traumatized
i see the pain in my momma she know i
just might drop any day but i'm still
through anyway we gonna make this money
any in each way hold on down you know
yo [ __ ] that you know that yo i come
from a place where young is towing guns
bigger than them easier to shot the
bigger the room that's how they want it
i've been out just [ __ ] on the
ponies yeah i've been out just [ __ ]
on the ponies that smoke down warning
upgrading my sweat now nice witty y'all
upgrading my sweat now nice sweetie ice
with it he really want that smoke no
[Music]
where you come from yeah come from a
place where young and told guns bigger
than them ain't trippin cause that boy
ain't got bigger than him easier to shot
the bigger the run that's how they want
it y'all i've been in the streets
chasing money ain't too much tripping on
the whole she know how i go when i come
on [ __ ] then i'm leaving i ain't
pleasing hold on yo i ain't pleasing
none y'all hold on and we go and get the
money i ain't too much worried about
nothing else get the money i ain't too
much worried about none of us as long as
my family's straight and we gon make
sure everybody eating hold on
yo this [ __ ] comes straight up off the
top you know how that go how long
straight up off the top you know how
that go switch flows he could [ __ ]
around i came up from kicking kick
though hold on i came up from hitting
kick those licks for real i wasn't on
bricks for real i was cutting sticks
real i was coming up trying to go and
hit a lick for real i was down on my
dick for real hold on i was mad had a
picture fit for real yo i don't know how
they feel
you know i don't know how they feel but
i'ma stick the door on me i don't know
how they feel but i'ma stick the door on
me regardless on the beat i go with
tallest
hey man yo shout out to your social
media all that [ __ ] plus you by the way
congrats you just had a baby right yeah
callie i just had my baby just dropped
shout out to social media where people
can find you at man yeah you are on the
scout blp they know what it is
low bob man repping south carolina let's
go